it's a one division finale time people i
know a lot of people tend to
you know probably skip the intros and
just hop straight to the reaction this
is gonna be a part one and part two i
know most people will probably just go
right away to part two not even watch
part one but
i wanted to take a moment to um probably
gonna be a little cheesy right here
i did want to just say thank you to
everyone who's been watching our videos
anything one division related i really
mean it when i say that this has been
like a real experience we've covered
other shows before but
something about the experience of one
division has just been very different i
haven't watched it yet but i'm already
gonna miss the show yeah i know this is
not the last we're gonna be talking
about wandavision
it's been a long time since it's really
felt like we were all gathered around
the show and
wrapped with attention and not being
able to wait until we could discuss the
details the next day and so that for
this to be the final episode it is like
oh guys we're yeah we're at the end of
an era here i mean we had like other
shows
but nothing quite like this for at least
on our personal end
so yeah go ahead hit that like button
and subscribe
hit the notification bell full-length
ratchet and watch along it's pretty
single with the time coder at our
patreon page thank you to everyone who's
followed us at our patreon for all the
shows that we cover over there and also
thank you to eric over at nerd chronic
for editing the reaction highlights for
us
uh you rock man and you're like the best
at editing so
you are thank you you're the king thank
you man uh yeah
let's get into this guys let's have some
let's have some fun
[Music]
my powers work out here did you forget
i'm counting on it
of course she wants to see what he's
capable of
go to your room agatha go to your room
i take power from the undeserving
okay so she wants the scarlet witch
gross so why don't you
surrender your magic to someone who
knows what to do with it
she slammed the corner she's spiderman
tudor
just the boots
oh no
[Music]
1000 over here this is our home
then let's fight for it
awesome waste your breath babe
no one can hear you from in here
you must be destroyed
way to go buddy oh yeah
oh hell yeah
dude this is the first like full on
action
you'll never be able to cover this up if
only you had a little more
vision you're a dick ah you're a dick
hey
[Music]
did you know there's an entire chapter
devoted to you
in the dark hole the dark horn confirmed
the scarlet witch is not born she is
forged
no one taught me magic your power
exceeds that of the sorcerer's supreme
your destiny to destroy the world
dottie wanda dottie i have a daughter
she's a she could be friends with your
boys
if you like that storyline or uh the
school bully even
i guess daddy's not that special witch
that we were yeah i think
she might behave serious
oh no they're all being awakened
no
ralph he is ralph theory two
ralph boner
damn you're getting a damn good holding
your powers
[Music]
what are you doing what are you doing
what
all these poor people
what are you doing
she's getting rid of it
awesome and powerful sam ray was
directing there
best use of a sky beam in a long time
yeah it's not about this guy being
really
oh no vision
no vision
let's see
[Music]
has these glitching effects
save west view or save your family
oh jesus christ
oh man what the hell is going to happen
i have no idea
[Music]
nice there you go wanda protective magic
come on
oh no never mind
[Music]
oh sweet
um dad monica where are you
oh good
your mother and i never really prepared
you for this but
you were born damn right they were
oh my programming directive is to
destroy the vision
you guys are just destroying me but not
the true vision
only a conditional vision
vision confusion vision consternation
i request elaboration vision elaboration
visual aberration
make her worthy of her magique
moana's doing heroic [ __ ] military
yes
wait oh thank god okay i was like what
if he's good
there you go
oh the wicked was like
[Music]
darcy
all right guys that's the end of part
one click the card
end screen pin comment description box
to go watch our part two for three
that's the one
most juicy stuff is that